papa de maudore l'unanimité à maurice
pialat ou sous le soleil de satan 15
1987 face à une salle qui lui conteste
sa palme d'or pour cent sous le soleil
de satan
maurice cas là entre dans la légende du
festival le poing vengeur
je suis surtout content ce soir pour
tous les cris et les sifflets que vous
m'adressez et si vous ne m'aimez pas je
peux vous dire que je ne vous aime pas
non plus il est vrai que maurice pialat
à la mauvaise réputation qu'ont souvent
les hommes de passion
ses détracteurs lui reprochent ses coups
de gueule et ses engagements sans
concession c'est parti dans la dore
exactement pour les mêmes raisons moi
j'ai dû m'aider très frappé par là
l'intelligente et là l'amour du cinéma
qu'il a mûri ce cas là ce fut entre
autres le réalisateur du gard sud de van
gogh de police dans nos amours et de
loulou ce fut aussi l'un des cinéastes
préférés de gérard depardieu
cela parce que dans la vie comme dans
ses films il était toujours d'une
authentique sincérité c'est quelqu'un de
libre donc automatiquement la rébellion
je crois libre et qui savaient le prix
de la liberté très cher
service je viens de voir les russes
comme uche est à pousser son prix
j'étais glacé des lames sont montées aux
yeux
cet homme il comprend engagé et
douloureux aussi et dont la vie se
confond avec l'oeuvre fait aujourd'hui
l'objet d'un documentaire
on y découvre une personnalité complexe
et surtout un artiste torturé et votre
passionnant et je laisserais